[Musica]
a grandissima richiesta nuovissimi
scherzi alla maestra perché sono usciti
tantissimi nuovi scherzi in più lei ha
trovato un fidanzato
dobbiamo rovinare sarà l'appuntamento
insomma non vedo l'ora di giocare e
vedere i nuovi scherzi perché adoro
questo gioco e so che lo adorate anche
voi quindi lasciate un bel mi piace se
volete altri gameplay con scary teacher
mettetevi comodi prende tifo carne
allora scheri teacher e sta per il suo
piatto speciale con il suo fidanzato
quindi noi dobbiamo rovinare il piatto
speciale chiediamo che dice speriamo che
non ci siano delle altre sorprese dice
dei vermi allora dobbiamo scegliere che
arma utilizzare il gas che la fa ridere
oppure la chiave oro all energia che si
ricarica di verifica nell'apparato di ok
allora che cosa si sono detti prima al
telefono che difficile il suo povero
fidanzata
in pratica lei ha detto di andare
da lei a cena stasera per un
appuntamento aromatico che lei cucinerà
il suo piatto speciale ma noi dobbiamo
rovinarlo emettere i vermi dentro e ha
messo i lucchetti per non farsi rovinare
la serata giustamente questo primo
scherzo lo fa vitale che vi tenevo molto
più bravo bravissimo presi scherzi
abbiamo così che visiterò poi dove tra i
miei bellissimi capelli su sei saranno
giro i miei capelli e bruttissima come
un po più sua forza registri così bella
mi raccomando anche voi controllate
sempre dalla telecamera dove sta andando
ieri fitch ha fatto una faccia strana no
no per fortuna però stiamo piangendo
perché è un trucco per riuscire a
giocare bene a questo gioco e
controllare le telecamere per vedere che
non si stia avvicinando ma dobbiamo
cercare la stanza in cui c'era il
barattolo con i vermi da mettere nel
cibo si cerca di le roviniamo
l'appuntamento e lì mi sono posto giusto
in tempo
ecco le terme coli e.coli attento di
trappole questo intanto è stranissimo fa
paura
ok ok allora adesso dobbiamo andare in
cucina e dovrebbe stare al piano di
sotto la cucina possiamo farcela
ho paura che sia qui vicino non riesco a
capire dove sono così forse un passaggio
segreto questo aiuto lazio sia in cucina
vedi scassa già un brillante forse è
proprio questa la porta ok allora non
possiamo andare ad esse cucina perché
lei ha appena girato il suo piatto e ha
detto che il miglior chef dell'umana
questa cucina non ho lei è andato e
adesso dobbiamo scappare ma c'è una
trappola c'è una trappola detto dove
scappo adesso non lo so dovete qua paura
che si sia vedi qua si nascondano quali
nascondono mi nascondo 3 milioni
si ok diciamo una ventina di lontano di
cucina vediamo vediamo lorenzo youtube è
arrivato fidanzato è arrivato vorrei uno
spento e con timore al proprio uno
scherzo prossimo scherzo che ricchezza
che stiamo misti e il fidanzato devono
insomma fare una performance di ballo
gli ho prestato ai piedi sta arrabbiando
e saliceto strutture fiera in mezzo ai
piedi
ok ora devo scegliere una di quelle
abilità e scelgo il gas che farle che
siamo all'entrata ciò che dovete
domandare guarda una macchina del fumo
mi fosse la premier e poi che cosa c'è
altro vediamo o no guarda latino si
vedono dopo è fato provati dalla pesca
la nonna risotto forse meglio stesso
anno scorso acquaviti che si sta
avvicinando sempre molto bassa
per evitare che è molto più bravo come
avete potuto vedere che riti germi
prende sempre comunque c'è scritto che
spiriti inter c'è la chiamano t quindi
in realtà si chiamava ti qualcosa di
come si stia girando comunque meno
abbiamo ancora i nostri oggetti promossa
dire da fare la carta è una scorciatoia
guarda la foto di scari teaser juve non
è vero non l'avevamo visto cioè di cui
dire che lei ha fatto un concorso di
bellezza lo apre vinto porterà a
photoshop o quello
la sua camera da letto perché pieno di
scatola si vorrà trasferire un'altra
casa di attenzione alle trappole
comunque secondo me la casa di scary
teacher è troppo grande si veda in
trappole per topi
c'è scritto metti le trappole per topi
nel dance floor che si dice italiano nel
sobborgo verifica me la dava ballo
questa porta è chiusa da dove possono
scappare ho paura che lei stia vedendo
proprio qui si salute
ok per fortuna si erano ancora in mano
le la trappola che essi subito per ci
proviamo
nessuna paul ama delegate a te
[Musica]
ok ok non mi dovevo trovare sono il
posto in cui balleranno spiriti c'era il
povero fide dato come mi sa che è chiuso
ma è un labirinto anche il giardino che
potrebbe essere una potenziale trappola
se non stiamo attenti
oppure una piscina in oro
ecco però l'abbiamo trovato perché mette
subito né troppo
sì sì trappole messe allontanati
giovanissimi mettere la macchina per il
fumo che abbiamo poche ore prima ok ok
ora che cosa devi fare forse deviazione
la musica azionando la musica ricordi se
di inviare un messaggio o il fidanzato
lungo il greto facciamo un altro insomma
era dopo klose comunque era qualcosa
tipo balliamo nuovamente assieme quindi
abbiamo inviato un messaggio da parte
nostra c'è da parte di scary t3 al
fidanzato potrebbe scappare adesso
speriamo tanto è scattata sta scappando
arrivando non vedo l'ora di vedere come
si che non è stata la cucina non da qui
io intanto parlato gambe o una che esca
fuori davanti non sta andando dalla
cucina per fortuna o terna non avrebbero
se meno male sicuro loro te io comunque
per essere tranquillo anche perché si
arrabbierà vediamo vediamo che cosa
succede
eccola sta andando con molta calma
quando deve prenderci corre sentito gli
facciamo gli scherzi valentino ecco
[Musica]
e in mezzo al fumo non se ne sono
accorti delle trappole quindi boeri da
ok prossimo scherza al ritiro è molto
felice del suo nuovo trampolino
penso che potremo fargli un velo per
cento vediamo un po sono così contento
di andare con trampolino oggi cari
soprattutto stiamo facendo soprattutto
quanto si sta bene senza bambini in giro
come ti permette lo facciamo uno
scherzetto il cactus deboli e poi li si
salta sopra e farai una brutta fine
allora ce lo teniamo qui per dopo a 40
fuori dalla finestra forse ci sta lui
sta spirando dalla finestra per avere
qui no roma dopo lo ritengo nella
casetta dove ci sono sua figlia patrioti
possiamo prendere
allora questo per entrare dentro casa
sicuramente le forbici
sì possiamo tagliare il trampolino con
le forbici secondo te ci riusciremo
lei si sta dirigendo fuori atene
tornando verità la porta va beh ma tanto
noi poi riusciamo a fare il giro dei ha
perso la partita fuori attenzione
giardino o no
ecco il cactus che abbiamo appoggiato lì
tutto storto ma date le bresciane con
questa vediamo si è rotto il trampolino
ma così però lei se ne accorge vita dice
adesso dobbiamo scappare però perché sta
arrivando proprio qui dobbiamo
raccoglierlo in qualche modo si sta
arrivando a tiziana arrivato
allontana dai ne sono in giro d'acqua
dietro ho fatto un giro
formare pare non ho affatto il giro è in
formissima spiritismo la cosa perché
velocemente tripoli non fermarti aiuta
la vicinissima gironcino musica che
ansia dai si stancherà prima o poi tornò
dai st hediger vabbè tanto dovevo
comunque tra le dentro casa quindi per
me è più comodo ok siamo quasi salvi
quasi quanti punti forse qui non si
tocca che entriamo dal passaggio segreto
e cioè le scale spero che lei non sia
già salita sopra non si strappa ok io ti
dico io dove sta offrire la postura
finalmente ha smesso di girare però a
casa e si è seduta nel divano e
ovviamente già arrivata qui guarda
veramente cammina sopra il tavolo
nell'aria buffon si capisse 15 gare
questa cosa per ricucire il capo ii
nomino salendole scarsa sta in vasca
nella quale a barbara ci sono dei figli
così sì sì sì no no non me lo fa fretta
stata
[Musica]
i primi a montare ho paura che sia più
vicino dove volevo scappare dobbiamo
scappare se per caso non si stanca mai
ha già messo la trappola ovviamente
scappa numero chiuso
ok riprendiamo allora li fronte che
usiamo il pilot la porta il sensore di
share e bravissimo ok allora al milan
oltre a polino vediamo vediamo se ce la
facciamo
abbiamo poco tempo tra l'altro
pochissimo
oppure il tempo o no non mi dire che
stanno uscendo
sì purtroppo sì ma forse ce la facciamo
dai metti il filo anche il cactus e ha
messo il cactus molino a fare sempre di
sugano start stop è stato solo
nascondere non lei è in cucina forse è
così no che sì allora vide uno scatto
devo proprio scappare da qui perché
sennò esce proprio di fronte a mare
[Musica]
dai speriamo che ce la facciamo
eccola sta arrivando guarda che parte
sta arrivando sta andando verso la
piscina verso trappolino dove vi è il
trampolino il via la ok ok ok allora
forse non ci vede qua vediamo come
reagisce
io sono troppo corredo a vivere a
rischio ecco i cactus sotto continuano
gli sta togliendo tutte le speranze del
[Risate]
bravo anche questa volta glielo abbiamo
pato finiti i privati cd conventicole
state questo scherzo preferito per me
quest'ultimo mi ha fatto noi che secondo
lei questo è stato il più bello debole
che facciamo altri scherzi con scritti
sono state un bel mi piace su questo
video e ora vi lasciamo 4 nel sellino e
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite la
vista